Are you sure you don't wanna tell me your name?
Positive.
I'm having much too much fun.
Alright, if you wanna play games.
Have you always lived here in Long Island?
Most of my life.
I could have sworn I knew every pretty girl on the North Shore.
I could have sworn you took in more territory than that.
This is maddening!
I know I've seen that face before.
Let me see your profile again.
I know I know you.
I have a feeling I've seen you... with your father.
Wait a minute! Is your father Admiral Starratt?
Hardly.
It's funny, I keep seeing him in a uniform.
Oh, come on! Give me a hint.
What does your father do?
He's in transportation.
Transportation?
Railroads. New York Central?
No.
Planes. TWA?
Boats. United States Lines?
No.
I pass.
Automobiles.
Oh? Chrysler?
Yes. Chrysler and Ford, and General Motors, and Rolls-Royce.
Is your father on the board of directors of all those companies?
Well, you might say he runs things.
I bet my brother Linus knows him.
He certainly does.
As a matter of fact, they quite often drive into town together.
They do?
Straight through to the garage please.
I feel so stupid, I could kill myself.
You'll be alright in a minute.